Democrats announced their impeachment
charges the Inspector General of the DOJ
releases his report on the Trump Russia
collusion investigation and Hillary
still is not going away I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show the Ben
Shapiro show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your online privacy today at
expressive VPN comm slash Ben we're
gonna get to all the breaking news and
there is a lot of breaking news
momentarily first let me just tell you
there's a feel chaotic out there it's
about to feel a lot more chaotic because
the Democrats have now announced their
impeachment charges well one thing's
feel chaotic people tend to seek safe
haven and one of the places they seek
safe haven financially is in precious
metals why well you got to diversify I
mean the fact is if the stock market
takes a hit usually the stock market
moves in tandem or actually in inverse
to the prices of precious metals because
people see precious metals as a way of
hedging against the possibility of
economic downturns mean they're solid
assets well the people I trust when it
comes to precious metals investment are
the people over at Birch gold
you're a smart investor Birch gold has
been with me since their beginning
literally our very first advertiser on
the show when they are now putting out
an offer that I've never seen them
actually put out before it's the silver
stocking stuffer event say that five
times fast when you contact Birch gold
group this month to buy precious metals
once you complete your purchase before
December 20th Birch gold will send you
free silver which is a great stocking
stuffer or Konica gift or Christmas gift
is the case may be open your account
with Birch gold group today get free 100
percent silver have a conversation with
the Birch gold expert ask all your
questions make sure you feel comfortable
and then when you're ready to invest
used all because they really are honest
and they're great guys this is worth it
text Ben to 47 47 47 claim your
eligibility for this special offer today
again text Ben to 47 47 47 text Ben to
47 47 47 all right so the Democrats have
finally come forth and announced their
impeachment charges they've announced
the impeachment charges Wow and and they
were very they were very confident about
announcing those impeachment charges
nothing says you're gonna fight
corruption like standing at a podium
being flanked by Maxine Waters probably
most corrupt member of Congress in
modern American history nothing says
that you take the law seriously like
putting next to you aunty Maxine who has
suggested from the very beginning that
Donald Trump should be impeached
literally the day of Jerry Nadler
York announced the impeachment charges
today he was flanked as I say by Maxine
Waters and by Nancy Pelosi looking very
serious and grimacing at the camera this
demonstrates has serious they are
they're not doing this gleefully they're
not doing this politically they're just
doing this because they love the
Constitution so here is Jerry Nadler
announcing the charges in service to our
duty to the Constitution and to our
country the House Committee on the
judiciary is introducing two articles of
impeachment charging the President of
the United States Donald J Trump with
committing high crimes and misdemeanors
the first article is for abuse of power
it is an impeachable offense for the
President to exercise the powers of its
public office to obtain an improper
personal benefit while ignoring or in
injuring the national interest this
gives rise to the second article of
impeachment for obstruction of Congress
here too we see a familiar pattern and
president Trump's misconduct a president
who declares himself above
accountability above the American people
and above Congress's power of
impeachment which is meant to protect
against threats to our democratic
institutions is the president who sees
himself as above the law ok this is an
absurdity on its face it's an absurdity
I mean truly absurd and the reason you
can tell us is absurd is because they
were originally thinking of three
charges right not two three the third
charge was going to be bribery bribery
is an actual federal crime and with
elements that you have to fulfill now as
a lawyer if you're going to try and push
impeachment charges typically what you
want is an actual crime rates as high
crimes and misdemeanors now listen
impeachment is inevitably a political
affair you can impeach for anything
legally speaking you don't actually have
to convict somebody of a crime in order
to impeach them if you just don't like
the president you could theoretically
impeach them but the reason that the
founders wrote high crimes and
misdemeanors into the Constitution of
the United States is specifically
because they were suggesting they might
actually have to fulfill some elements
of criminality so the Democrats had
originally their narrative was that
Donald Trump had traded
military aides Ukraine in return for
getting Joe Biden then they brought in
that out say he traded military aid and
a meeting with President Vladimir
Solinsky of Ukraine in return for
getting Joe Biden then they broaden that
out to say no it was just Donald Trump
trying to do something not necessarily
by Joe Biden just something that we
don't like in return for military aid
from Ukraine and at that point at the
point when it shifted then the crime
element sort of went away because the
fact is the evidence did not support
their original charges the original
charge was that Donald Trump tried to
militarized military aid to Ukraine in
order to push the Ukrainians to dig up
dirt on Joe Biden in anticipation of the
2020 election and from best defense
always and forever was that he did not
have the requisite intent for that
because bribery is an intent crime the
defense would have been and remains that
President Trump was simply looking back
at 2016 he was angry about 2016
he saw Ukraine as corrupt he didn't like
giving aids Ukraine anyway because he
tends to be isolationist when it comes
to having foreign aid and when he looks
at Ukraine's interference in the 2016
election which yes it had was it the
same level as the Russians of course not
did it happen well according to Politico
and the New York Times it did happen and
Trump knew that and so he sent Rudy
Giuliani over there to dig up dirt on
the Ukraine right on on 2016 and all the
nefarious connections between the Obama
administration and Ukraine and to take
up dirt on corruption inside Ukraine and
all of the rest of this stuff he did all
that with an eye toward 2016 9 9 toward
2020 some of that is in the national
interest some of that is not the
national interest the only thing that
would certainly not have been in the
national interest in here is where the
Democrats run into trouble the only
thing that certainly would not have been
in the national interest is Trump
attempting to dig up corruption on Joe
Biden for purposes of 2020 not for
purposes of 2016 right for purposes of
2020 that would have been Trump just
seeking specific political benefit for
himself in anticipation of an upcoming
election by using a corrupt foreign
government as his tool as his cutout
okay that was the original accusation
that I'm across were making remember
they haven't been making that accusation
anymore and the fact that they did not
put bribery on the list of impeachable
charges demonstrates they don't have
anything remotely approaching
actual convictable criminal conduct
remember a few weeks ago there
Kratts were suggesting that Trump could
actually be prosecuted for this not just
that he'd be impeached but it could be
prosecuted from him for violation of
federal bribery statutes they moved
remember linguistically from quid pro
quo to bribery originally they said was
a quid pro quo and then they said well
the American people don't understand
quid pro quo quid pro quo
did happen right Mick Mulvaney the OMB
the head of the Office of Management of
budget he said that did happen the
question was was it an improper quid pro
quo which amounts to bribery or was it
just kind of a yucky quid pro quo that
wasn't criminal but also was not great
which is the reality because but the
Democrats are not charging bribery today
why because again you have to fulfill
certain elements in the Democrats don't
have it what are the elements of federal
bribery the elements of federal bribery
under 18 USC 201 it describes several
ways to violate its provisions
criminalizing bribing a public official
provides whoever directly or indirectly
corruptly gives offers or promises
anything of value to any public official
or person who has been selected to be a
public official to influence any
official act to influence such public
official to commit fraud to induce such
public official shall be fine or in
prison for not more than 15 years or
both so if you want to bribe a public
official and it would work both ways you
need a public official the defendants
corrupt intent the intent matters in
other words it's corrupt intent specific
corrupt intent something of value
offered and information generally has
not been deemed to be a thing of value
and this came up earlier on in the
campaign when there were earlier on in
the in Trump's presidency when there was
talk about whether if Trump had received
information from foreign sources in the
2016 election whether that would have
amounted to a campaign finance violation
right because the idea was that you're
not allowed to get donations from
foreign sources for campaigns is it a
donation if you find out from a foreign
source information about your political
opponent and the best answer is
typically not usually when information
flows information is information it is
not considered a thing of value so there
are two elements missing from the
bribery statute that don't apply in this
case one is the anything of value
because here you'd be looking for
presumably information and two is the
exact corrupt intent okay so that those
elements are missing the Democrats know
that which is why the impeachable
offenses they put out today are not
actual crimes they are not actual
in the end the impeachable offenses the
democrats are putting forth today are
almost entirely empty the only reason I
say almost as opposed to entirely empty
is because again I don't buy the
trumpian notion that he did nothing
wrong it was a perfect phone call
everything was hunky-dory it was all on
the up-and-up
the Ukraine was the country that was
actually interfering in the 2016
election CrowdStrike Purisima like I
don't buy a lot of that stuff but that
that's the only reason I'm saying almost
the fact is Trump could have done a lot
of stuff that you don't like that I
don't like that I think is yucky and it
doesn't rise anywhere near the level of
impeachable because it's not even a
crime you couldn't charge the guy in
court for this kind of stuff so what are
the two charges okay so charge number
one is abuse of power abuse of power so
Jerry Nadler announcing these charges
said is it it is an impeachable offense
for the president to exercise the power
of his public office to obtain an
improper personal benefit while ignoring
or injuring the national interest okay
that last phrase is so vague as to be
completely non colorable I mean there's
just no way to interpret that phrase
with any limiting principle whatsoever
so Jerry Nadler says it's an impeachable
offense for the president who exercised
the power of his public office to obtain
an improper personal benefit so that's
number one
improper personal benefit so what's the
improper personal benefit here
presumably it would have been Trump
receiving some sort of announcement that
Biden was going to be investigated is
that improper or not well it depends
again because it goes back to the intent
question the only reason that would be
improper is because Trump knew
presumably maybe that Biden is innocent
and he wants Ukraine to announce an
investigation into an innocent guy to
damage him politically but what if Trump
actually believes that that Biden's kind
of guilty of stuff back in 2016 what if
he believes that that requires more
investigation
what if he believes in other words the
bill of goods that Rudy Giuliani has
been selling him and that he's been
reading in John Solomon at the hill is
that now him receiving an improper
personal benefit or is that Trump acting
in the public interest you don't know
and that is why the key to the Democrat
charge here is the broadening out of the
notion of intent the broadening out of
the notion of intent remember bribery
requires intent for me to get something
from you for a corrupt purpose and
bribery is not you and I
make an exchange of goods where every
market transaction is a quid pro quo
it literally means this for that right
so that last phrase while ignoring or
injuring the national interest is
extraordinarily different from specific
intent to commit a bribery offense
because ignoring the national interest I
can charge Barack Obama with ignoring
the national interest for like eight
years I think every single thing that
Barack Obama did for pretty much a
teeters was ignoring or injuring the
national interest that's not an intent
crime that is not an intent crime there
is no intent there ignoring or injuring
the national interest is not a standard
of intent
he's to take another intent crime take
another intent crime so let's say let's
say I punch you in the face so there's a
difference between I'm walking down the
street and suddenly I'm scared by dog
and I lean back and I hit you in the
face you're standing right behind me I
hit you in the face
hey and there's a different scene that
criminally speaking and me turning
around and just clocking you directly in
the face right one I had the intent to
clock you and one is negligence one is
negligence right one is that I didn't
know you were behind me I I didn't care
that you were behind me maybe that would
be reckless but in one case I would have
specific intent to harm you right I turn
around and I just punch you the other
would be quote ignoring or injuring you
right I'm ignoring or injuring you it's
not the same thing as I turn around and
punch you I don't know you're there I'm
ignoring you I injure you and I hurt you
is that the same thing is that the same
kind of activity the answer of course is
no one of those I would go to jail for
one of them at best maybe I'd have to
pay some sort of small tort settlement
for okay those are not the same thing at
all that is why the Democrats are
charging abuse of power and they are not
charging bribery they could not prove
intent so instead of saying listen we
can't prove intent we got no crime here
they're manufacturing a crime to fit the
activity they're manufacturing a charge
to fit what they think Trump did what
they think they can get him for that's
an amazing thing what they are doing
right now that's an abuse of power
that's an abuse of power imagine a
prosecutor who doesn't like me and so
instead of the crime being me assaulting
you right me performing a battery upon
you turning around punching you in the
face the crime becomes well just for
Shapiro if he leaps back and
accidentally hits you
that's ignoring or injuring you so we're
gonna charge him pretty much the same
way we would as if he had turn around
just face that is a prosecutorial
misconduct case in a nutshell and that
is what Democrats are doing right here
I'll get some more of this in just one
second first let me ask you are you
comfortable right now I don't mean like
emotionally come from I mean physically
comfortable are you physically
comfortable right now well if you
feeling a little uncomfortable you're
squirming in your seat perhaps it is
because the inter wear that you
currently have gracing your tuchus is
not exactly the world's best underwear
well let me tell you what the world's
best underwear would be like first of
all I have a brand I know be called
Tommy John because that stuff is
supremely comfortable at graces this
very took us at this very moment you
should start to think about the perfect
holiday gift for him or her and Tommy
John should be the first thing that
comes to mind Tommy John is a
revolutionary underwear loungewear and
clothing brand that guarantees a perfect
fit by the way it works great for women
my wife wears Tommy John also she's
raving about the quality of their
product Tommy John is here to save your
holiday season with gifts to eliminate
awkward adjustments for men and women
they create innovative products like
breathable wedgie-proof underwear and
ridiculously soft loungewear and pajamas
that are guaranteed to fit perfectly the
wedgie-proof underwear that would been
so helpful in highschool let me tell
Tommy John uses lightweight breathable
fabrics with multi-directional stretch
so their bras and underwear can fit any
type of body plus you never get that
wedgie leave the jingling to the bells
and give the gift of comfort this
holiday with limited-edition gifts like
loungewear pajamas and underwear from
Tommy John plus you save 20% on your
first order when you visit Tommy John
comm / Ben that is Tommy John comm / Ben
for 20% off again Tommy John comm / Ben
you get 20% off great holiday gift
giving and you get it for not as
expensive as it would be otherwise Tommy
John comm / Ben ok so that first charge
is really the key charge abuse of power
but again that is not the definition of
a crime it's not even close to a crime
in fact as I say it looks like they have
now tailored the crime to fit the
activity when they launched this thing
they thought they were going to come up
with an actual overt bribe instead they
couldn't come up with anything remotely
approaching it because again they
weren't and they don't think they will
either let's point that out because this
shades into crime number two that
they're talking about they believed that
they were going to get Trump on the
bribery offense the bribery offense did
not materialize there's only one witness
that they even talked to in the house
Intel
odin's committee who had he ever had a
conversation ever with Donald Trump
Gordon someone that's it not a single
other person they had ever talked with
had a conversation with Donald Trump
I believe it at all but certainly about
Ukraine and Gordon someone did not give
them the intent so if you're the
Democrats you have two choices at that
point one is you move forward with the
bribery charge but you wait to actually
move forward with that until you talk to
the people who have talked to Trump
so you subpoena say Rudy Giuliani you
subpoena Mick Mulvaney you subpoena John
Bolton you subpoena vice-president pence
you subpoena everybody who's around
Donald Trump who had a direct
conversation with Donald Trump Secretary
of Energy repairing all of them and then
you wait for the courts to adjudicate
the subpoenas and then you talk to them
and maybe they give you the goods maybe
they don't and then you move forward
from there
that'd be the honest way to do this
Democrats didn't do this Democrats knew
they weren't gonna get the intent crime
from any of these people because they
know that the actual charge is nonsense
they know that Trump did not engage in
bribery here he never had the intent for
bribery so instead they just dropped the
bribery charge entirely and they
tailored a charge that is not an actual
crime now listen did they have the legal
ability to do this of course again
impeachment some political process they
can do whatever they want but when Jerry
Nadler defines the crime as it when he
says it's an impeachable offense for the
president to exercise the power of his
public office to obtain an improper
personal benefit while ignoring or
injuring the national interest that is
not an impeachable offense the
definition is not impeachable I can name
you a dozen items off the top of my head
that President Bush Clinton Obama every
president does that I believe obtained
an improper personal benefit for that
person while ignoring or injuring the
national interest particularly if the
improper personal benefit is election
driven because let's be frank about this
the President of the United States in
his first term is very much concerned
with his reelection effort and so he
does things with an eye toward
reelection efforts do you really think
the Barack Obama didn't care about his
reelection everything he did was for the
good of the country never once did
across Barack Obama's mind that what he
was doing had some sort of ramifications
for 2012
for Barack Obama really the most obvious
example Barack Obama is sitting across a
chair there's a small table he shouldn't
cross the table from Dmitri Medvedev who
is a stand-in for Vladimir Putin
he's Putin's Lackey his lapdog and Putin
Obama says on a hot mic - Dmitry
Medvedev I will give your man
Putin I'll give more flexibility after
the election so basically cool your jets
please stop being aggressive until after
the election because then I'll have more
flexibility ok is that the president in
obtaining an improper personal benefit
while ignoring or injuring the national
interest by this standard a hundred
percent yes absolutely
undoubtedly and when Barack Obama was
was sending deploying his camber
campaign resources I mean literally
taking his Chiefs of campaign and
sending them to Israel in order to go
after Benjamin Netanyahu and oust him
from office he actually had his campaign
people go to Israel to try and defeat
Netanyahu in an election in Israel was
that Barak Obama attempting to obtain
them proper personal benefit he had
personal animus for Netanyahu was he
ignoring or injuring the national
interest I would say sure again none of
that was impeachable because all of that
is well within the purview of
presidential activity we have now moved
actually to ace this is almost a strict
liability definition of a crime ignoring
or injuring the national interest is not
even an intent crime you know I'm seeing
there's an article at Reason magazine
today talking about how they're trying
to impeach Trump for corrupt intent no
that's wrong they're not even attempting
to impeach Trump for corrupt intent
they're suggesting you don't even need
corrupt intent all you need is the mere
presence of a situation where you can
impute to the person corrupt intent you
don't have to prove corrupt intent if
you could prove corrupt intent you have
a bribery offense you don't have to
prove corrupt intent that's the point
all you have to do is show that he is
quote unquote ignoring or injuring the
national interest well think about your
own personal relationships think about
your spouse think about your friends how
many times do they think that they are
that you are ignoring them or injuring
their personal interest and you're not
right you literally are not you're not
ignoring them
you just have been busy for example and
my daughter is five that means that
every time she wants me to do something
it has to be done in the next 15 seconds
or I earn I am ignoring or injuring her
interest is that true or is that her
perception well the problem is they
haven't even proved that he ignored or
injured the national interest right and
by the way injuring the
general interest is a matter of
perspective because I may even agree
that Trump's perspective on Ukraine is
wrong and bad you should have given the
military aid but that's an opinion about
foreign policy and that is subject to
our elections elections are supposed to
decide whether you agree with the
candidates or in this case the incumbent
president on whether he is indeed
forwarding the national interest or
injuring the national interest ignoring
the national interest or pressing
forward the national interest
those are election questions to seize an
election question and criminalize an
election question is an abuse of power
but Democrats are doing here is an abuse
of power they don't have the goods if
they pushed censure they'd be perfectly
within their rights to push this as an
impeachable offense this is not a high
crime it's not a misdemeanor ain't
nothing it ain't nothing and that does
not mean that Donald Trump did
everything right here as I've said
before I think he did lots of bad wrong
things here but that is not the same
thing as a high crime and misdemeanor
that justifies impeachment okay so
that's charge number one and it's just
nonsense it's just nonsense okay then
there is the then there is the
obstruction of Congress charge okay so
this one is just absurdity on his face
so House Intelligence Committee Chairman
Adam Schiff who by the way it's so funny
you know Democrat Republicans keep
saying let's get shift to testify right
in front of House Judiciary Committee
let's get the guy who started this whole
thing with the whistleblower wrote the
300-page report and let's have this guy
testify and Schiff and Adler keep going
know is that obstruction of Congress
it's obstruction of Congress people for
sure it's obstruction of the minority so
are the way that we are supposed to
believe that obstruction works is that
if people want you to testify and you
say no this constitutes a crime now like
a high crime or misdemeanor
according to chef he said the evidence
is every bit as strong that president
from obstructed Congress fully and
without precedent and without basis in
law if allowed to stand it would
decimate Congress's ability to conduct
oversight of this President or any other
in the future leaving this president's
or those who follow free to be as
corrupt and malfeasant and incompetence
as they would like with no
accountability but they do have
accountability it's called an election a
president can be as incompetent as
incompetence is not an impeachable
offense incompetence is not an
impeachable offense and again when it
comes to corruption you gotta prove the
corruption or the American people can
vote on whether they think someone
is corrupt this is no president no
president has ever been impeachment in
an impeachment hearing or trial or
movement no president is according to
Washington Post has specifically and
only been accused of obstructing
Congress because typically it's lumped
in with an actual crime obstruction of
justice obstruction of justice so now
they're just saying Trump isn't doing
what we want him to do so we're going to
impeach him for that absolute garbage
absolute nonsense
I mean this is absurd it's absurd like
there is no legal grounds for this this
is the height of absurdity as I've said
if the Democrats wanted to go after from
for obstruction of justice all they
would have to do presumably is wait
because let's say they subpoena or
originally on it they haven't even
issued legal subpoenas to half the
people they say Trump is obstructing
let's say they issued a legal subpoena
to Mike Pompeo they issued a legal
subpoena to John Bolton okay and those
guys then went to a court and said you
know what we don't want to go appealing
and then the court said you have to go
and then Trump said you're not allowed
to go now you have an obstruction of
justice case all Democrats have to do is
wait like a month they won't do it
why because one they don't think they're
getting anything from those witnesses
and two they are manufacturing a charge
these are manufactured charges it is it
these are made up from whole cloth made
up from whole cloth obstruction of
Congress is not a crime that is called a
check-and-balance
that is written into the Constitution
the executive branch does not have to
listen to everything Congress says any
more than the Congress has to listen to
what the president has to say all this
happen it's not the way this works we'll
get some more of this in just one second
first then I love the Second Amendment
the reason I love the Second Amendment
because all the other amendments they
would not exist in the absence of the
Second Amendment you thought that the
founders well are you looking for that
perfect handgun for self-defense and
days at the range I have some great news
for you right now the u.s. CCA is giving
19 of my listeners a thousand bucks each
to buy the gun of their dreams that is
correct 19 of you could take home a
thousand bucks for free just text win
287 to 2 to 4 the official rules and to
lock in your 19 chances to win this all
ends on the 20th so you do have to hurry
the clock is ticking down on this one
remember you'll instantly get 19 three
chances to win you're a law-abiding
citizen you believe in the Constitution
you believe in the Bill of Rights well
then you should get
you should not II used weapon and it
should own a weapon and you know who
else believes that you SCCA simply text
win 287 2 2 2 right now to enter it's
easy you can enter in sentence in in
seconds the u.s. CCA has all sorts of
great services legal services and
informational services and training they
have all sorts of great stuff that you
need if you are a Second Amendment
devote a time is running out text win
287 to two to three or nineteen chances
to win that is win WI n to eight 7 2 to
2 again win to 8 7 2 to 2 and so this is
again an absurdity
there is no obstruction of Congress no
obstruction of Congress okay because
obstruction of Congress is just called
the president saying no I'm a separate
branch this happens all the time
obstruction of justice is when you
refuse a court word as a whole third
branch of government right Jonathan
Turley was pointing this out in his
testimony before the House Judiciary
Committee last week Democrats are met
these are now two completely
manufactured charges they are creating
charges out of whole cloth that have no
precedent in history or law none there's
no precedent the Washington Post admits
there is no precedent in history or law
for the idea that you can impeach solely
based on quote unquote obstruction of
Congress doesn't exist because again
obstruction of Congress put another way
is just called the executive branch is
unitary and the executive branch is not
subject to all of the whims of Congress
unless the judiciary agrees that the
executive branch's privileges are
overruled by the ability of Congress to
seek information if these sorts of
battles happen every single day between
the legislature and the executive that
is not obstruction of Congress any more
than it was obstructional Congress for
Barack Obama to declare privilege over
documents regarding Eric Holder in fast
and furious that was not obstruction of
Congress that was just called how this
stuff works
and when it comes to the first charge
the abuse of power charge again week
T you have now redefined the nature of
bribery to avoid the Troublesome
pitfalls of having to fulfill the
criminal elements that's what the
Democrats did here they took bribery the
CREM bribery they stripped it of the
corrupt intent and they stripped it of
the requirement that there be a thing of
value given in exchange
so they stripped the content of more
called it abuse of power and they said
he's guilty of that that's amazing stuff
if you're gonna charge somebody with
first-degree murder you have to prove
intent right that's one of the things
you have to prove in a first-degree
murder because first-degree murder is
typically thought of as murder with with
malice aforethought malice and intent to
forethought that you you planned it out
and you committed the murder let's say
that you didn't want to do that
so instead of charging manslaughter you
just said you know what we're not gonna
have that as part of the crime anymore
now you killed somebody strict liability
crime we're gonna consider it
first-degree murder you've changed the
nature of the law the crime itself
didn't change you change the nature of
the criminal definition that is what the
Democrats are doing right here I mean
this is that you're not gonna see a
single Republican defection along these
lines not one not one and Democrats are
gonna say well it's an abuse of power
abusive there's precedent for that I
mean there were abuse of power charges
against Nixon and Clinton there were
against Clinton there were actual
criminal charges in the impeachment
document against Nixon there were actual
document and by the way the house
actually voted down the abuse of power
allegation against President Clinton
they voted for the crime right than the
perjury stuff and the obstruction of
justice stuff they voted down the
Republican House voted down the abuse of
power allegation against Bill Clinton
under Newt Gingrich so this is just it's
a sham everybody understands it's a sham
and it's man if this doesn't blow back
on Democrats I'd be shocked because this
is they've gone so far over their skis
at this point I mean they are so far
beyond what the impeachment process was
supposed to do and this is coming from
somebody who was perfectly willing to
listen to all the evidence about Ukraine
again I'm not parenting the Trump
administration line that everything that
was a perfectly I don't believe that for
a second this is so far beyond the scope
of what impeachment is supposed to
achieve it is so far beyond the scope of
normal legality then it falls directly
into the category of abuse of power for
Democrats I mean this is a serious abuse
of power by Democrats so use the
impeachment process to redefine crimes
and then use that as sufficient as a
basis for impeachment is insane every
president from here on now it's getting
impeach basically as long as there is a
president of the opposite party in power
that is where there's
going again I can promise you a
half-dozen things off the top of my head
that Barack Obama did that fulfill the
Democrats definition of abuse of power
he receives an improper personal
benefits and ignored or injured American
interest how about his IRS going after
his direct political opponents in 2012
how about that that seems like kind of
fulfilling those elements doesn't it and
this is this is man the utter the utter
blatant nosov it is what's incredible
the partisan obviousness of it is what's
amazing
I thought the Democrats were smarter
than this apparently not apparently
they're just idiots and they decide
they've decided we have to go through
with this it doesn't matter whether we
have the grounds so we'll just make up
the ground basically we'll create a bill
of attainder for Donald Trump and then
we'll craft the crime to meet the fact
that we want Trump impeached that's what
we're talking about right here he'll get
into more of this in just one second
first let's talk about your sleep
quality so you got that really nice
mattress you got yourself the right
temperature in the room everything's
good got the blackout curtain you're
ready to go to sleep but there's
something that's making you
uncomfortable I'll tell you what it is
it is the sheets upon which you sleep
hey those sheets I know what you did you
went down to the local gas station
they're like it's an 800 thread count
sheet you like that sounds like a lot of
threads awesome
that's not how sheets work guys you need
to go get a great set of sheets you can
be spending like every night on them go
over to bowl and branch everything bull
and branch makes from bedding the
blankets is made from pure 100% organic
cotton they start out super soft they
get even softer over time you buy
directly from them so you're essentially
paying wholesale prices luxury sheets
can cost up to a thousand dollars in the
store but Bolin brand sheets are only a
couple of hundred bucks shipping is free
and you can try them for 30 nights there
is no risk and no reason to not give
them a try so go ahead try bull and
branch cheats you are going to love them
I love them so much that we actually got
rid of all the other sheets in our house
like it ruined other sheets for me they
are that good to get you started right
now my listeners get 50 bucks off your
first set of sheets at bull and branch
calm promo kleben go to bull and branch
calm today for 50 bucks off your first
set of sheets that is bol and branch
calm promo code Ben bull and branch calm
promo code Ben go check them out
right now I will get back into
impeachment stuff and also we'll review
this DOJ Inspector General report the
media are downplaying it the FBI was
great yep I wasn't great well get to
that in just a second first great news
game
got a perfect gift for you to give this
holiday season the gift of a daily wire
membership and we have a deal that's
right we have a deal so miss Black
Friday you missed Cyber Monday but don't
worry you're still getting the discount
from now until January 1st all inside
our plus gift memberships will be 25%
off all of them from now all the way
until January 1 that means your loved
one will get all the fantastic products
plus all of the left is tears inside the
majestic left is tears tumblr and you'll
get all the savings again that's 25% off
all insider plus gift memberships this
holiday season given the gift they will
thank you for it all year long go to
daily wire.com slash gift to get your
25% off again that is daily wire.com
slash gift to get your 25% off it's like
only from now until the end of the year
so you really want to get that gift
subscription in like right now makes a
great gift give the gift of joy to
yourself as well
daily wire comm slash gift use the slash
gift and get that 25% off we are the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay so the Democrats are trying to play
this is though they are very solid about
it indeed very very very so much
solemnity so Nancy Pelosi stood at the
Capitol called it a solemn act a solemn
act President Trump for his part has
said this is rank partisanship Jerry
Nadler
is pushing forward the idea and this is
really what the Democrats are pushing
this is such dangerous stuff seriously
it's dangerous for the country it's
dangerous for the country to push
forward an impeachment on the basis of
we don't like the guy and we're not even
going to attempt to mimic criminal
charges in the impeachment we're not I'm
going to attempted we're just gonna
basically say we don't like what he did
we can't find the crime but it's yucky
we're impeaching him for yucky you can't
impeach people for yucky we have
elections for yucky this is still a
republic you don't like Trump good news
he's up for election in a year all you
have to do is wait it out and in the
meantime watch your watch your stock
market increase seriously but the
Democrats are saying not just the the
impetus for this basically Democrats are
using as an excuse for pushing forward
an impeachment effort that has no actual
legal basis they're pushing forward as
an excuse for that that if they leave
Trump in place he will cheat and no
matter what happens in 2020 if he wins
he will have cheated
hey this is supremely dangerous I talked
about this a little bit yesterday on the
show it's incredibly incredibly
dangerous the Democrats in 2015-2016
they kept saying if Donald Trump doesn't
accept the results of this election well
that would be bad for the country I
agreed right Donald Trump in one of
those debates he said I don't know I
have to see how it goes I don't know and
I thought what the hell you can't do
that you can't do that if there is a
legal basis to challenge an election
then wait for the legal basis to
challenge an election but we cannot a
republic cannot survive the idea that
every time your opponent loses and every
time your opponent wins it's because he
that the system has been gamed otherwise
why live in a republic at all I mean
seriously if you don't trust the system
of voting to work then you ought to pick
up a gun because I thought that that was
pretty much the basis for the revolution
the basis for the Revolution was no
taxation without representation that the
colonies were not being properly
represented in British Parliament and so
the American people said no we're not up
for this we want our representation well
if you believe that the system is
designed to exclude you elect orally and
that no matter what from
if he wins that means that he has
cheated I mean isn't that the impetus
for isn't that the impetus for chaos and
violence moving forward seriously like
on a broader scale and so that's
providing the impetus for Democrats
impeachment efforts yeah we don't have
him on a crime but we need to get him
out because we don't get him out he's
gonna cheat again here's Jerry Nadler
saying that over the weekend we also
have faced with a very direct threat
that this president put himself
repeatedly above the interest of the
country and poses a threat to the
integrity of the next election that's
not something we were talking about 20
years ago he poses a threat to the
integrity of the next election if he's
allowed to continue to do what he's
doing okay so we don't have the grounds
for impeachment but we have to impeach
him because if we don't impeachment then
the next election will be illegitimate
what do you think by the way that the
other half of the American people who
voted for Trump think about that you
know they did 63 million Americans did
vote for Trump he is the president he
was duly elected via the electoral
college what do you think they think
about the legitimacy of a system where
you are misusing and abusing the power
of your authority to get rid of a guy
because you are preemptively suggesting
he's gonna cheat do you think that the
people on the other side are gonna trust
the system
so we've now built a system where nobody
trusts the system because now if Trump
is impeached in the house which you will
be and from loses what do you think
Trump's gonna say do you think Trump's
gonna sit there and he's gonna be like
no you know what everything was
hunky-dory everything's hunky-dory i
legit lost the election I'm a good sport
I'm going home who thinks Trump is gonna
do that or do you think the Trump is
going to militate outside the government
that he is going to that he's going to
micturate and then he's going to that
he's going to stew in his own juices and
he's going to suggest the Democrats
impeachment of him illegitimate drove
his approval ratings down and caused him
to lose and thus he was jobbed
we are now moving toward a 2020 election
where neither side is prepared to accept
the result of the 2020 election that is
dangerous stuff really dangerous and
again go back and listen my podcast in
2016 I said it was dangerous but
Democrats since 2016 have done nothing
but suggest that every election is
illegitimate Stacey Abrams is legit
governor of Georgia despite losing to
Brian Kemp by 55 thousand votes Donald
Trump is not the legitimate president of
the you never said the guy who is
sitting there saying the
2020 will be illegitimate he said that
President Trump was legally elected but
he said in January of 2017 that Donald
Trump was not the legitimate president
of the United States you can't have a
republic when everybody believes that
the system doesn't actually even go with
what the people say that every that
every election is is an act of theft and
we are getting into seriously dangerous
territory right here and Democrats are
embracing it embracing the Nancy Pelosi
for her part she says she says she has
not counted the votes in the house bull
crap bull crap you know what kind of
consequences will be brought to bear for
Democrats who do not vote along the
lines of impeachment here Pelosi says an
issue like this we don't count votes
people will just make their voices known
on it I haven't counted votes nor well
yeah sure sure I'm sure nobody's counted
votes at all President Trump for his
part went on Twitter and he said to
impeach a president who has proven
through results including perhaps
perhaps the strongest economy in our
country's history to have one of the
most successful presidencies ever and
most importantly who has done nothing
wrong his sheer political madness
hashtag 20/20 election and then he also
spent a lot of Monday tweeting about all
of this
now President Trump should say is that
this is an abuse of power by Democrats
they are crafting the crime to meet what
they think I did but even they can't
they can't even there's not a criminal
charger there's no criminal charges hey
Eliot angle of New York the Democratic
chairman of the Foreign Affairs
Committee he said I think there's a lot
of agreement a lot of us believe that
what happened with Ukraine especially is
not something we can just close our eyes
to notice the language again what hat I
mean this is deliberately vague language
what happened with Ukraine is something
we can't close our eyes to no one's
asking you to close your eyes you have a
lot of things you can do you can rip the
president via censure you can change his
funding priorities via Congress you do
run the purse but instead you've decided
to move forward with a process that
typically requires at least some
criminal conduct dan Goldman the
director of Investigations at the House
Intelligence Committee said President
Rome's persistence and continuing
efforts to coerce a foreign country to
help him cheat to win an election is a
clear and present danger to our free and
fair elections in to our national
security again this is Goldman appealing
to Democrats perception of 2016 and the
idea by Democrats that Trump stole the
2016 election
to suggest that he will steal the 2020
election so we don't need grounds to
impeach him that alone is enough grounds
to impeach him basically Trump won he
didn't win legitimately according to
Democrats therefore we have to stop him
in 2020 from even being on the ballot
president Trump has been tweeting
repeatedly assailing the witch hunt and
the do-nothing democrats Nadler said
that President Trump put himself before
country and he said the Trump's conduct
was clearly impeachable I mean again the
charges demonstrate just how empty these
claims are amazing amazing stuff I'm
really when I say I'm amazed I'm really
amazed that the Democrats did not at
least attempt to push forward with a
more audacious charge even if they
couldn't back it
I am shocked that they went with with
the weakness of these charges that again
do not rise to the level of criminal
activity okay meanwhile the other big
story of the day yesterday is that the
Inspector General Michael Horowitz of
the Department of Justice released his
report on the Trump restaurant collusion
investigation and the media's take on
the on the report is just completely
wrong and just completely wrong so team
Trump was saying this demonstrated there
was systemic problems inside the FBI
here is what the report actually found
okay so this is a media played this as
Trump needs to apologize to the FBI
because Trump had suggested the FBI was
corrupt top to bottom and that Trump had
ripped the intelligence community here
is is the the panel on CNN led by Chris
Cuomo saying Trump needs to apologize to
the FBI for all of his mean words about
the FBI wait until you hear what the IG
actually found about what the FBI did
here
the only arguable deep state activity
today was by this president's Attorney
General attacking the findings of his
own agency and having a hand-picked
prosecutor to justify his feelings about
spying doing his own probe and his
prosecutor pulled a Comey broke protocol
bad-mouth the inspector general's
findings while talking about his own
ongoing investigation so well those
accused of treason and worse get an
apology okay so no they won't get an
apology and also it turns out that what
the standard used by the IG in this
report is a very low
barré okay so all the IG was finding he
says that's in the report all he was
assessing is whether people violated the
law he was not assessing whether they
made good decisions or whether those
decisions were justified by evidence on
any real level he was simply asking
whether they met the baseline very bare
legal standard to not break the law so
in other words the IG was using the
proper standard when it comes to
prosecution the standard Democrats
actually should be using when it comes
to impeachment but he said I'm not
really assessing whether the
decision-making here was good and when
he says evidence of bias he's not saying
that Peter struck and leased a page
weren't biased he's saying the Peter
struck and Lisa page were unable to cram
through all of their priorities in this
investigation because there were other
people thank God who are part of the
process okay which is true and aside
from people who have been you know
wildly overestimating I don't know many
conservatives who are suggesting that
the entire FBI was corrupt now I was
saying yeah there are some bad apples
inside the FBI who obviously didn't like
Trump and we're pushing against him but
the idea that the entire FBI was
top-to-bottom corrupt I mean I know FBI
agents it's just nonsense
hey so here is what the IG actually
found so the standard used quote our
role in this review was not to
second-guess discretionary judgments by
Department personnel about whether to
open an investigation or specific
judgment calls made during the course of
an investigation where those decisions
complied with or were authorized by
department rules policies or procedures
we do not criticize particular decisions
merely because we might have recommended
a different investigative strategy or
tactic based on the facts learned during
our investigation so he's saying this
should not be read to be an assessment
of whether the right decisions were made
the only question is whether they broke
the law he said the question we
considered was not whether a particular
investigative decision was ideal or
could have been handled more effectively
but rather whether the Department and
the FBI complied with applicable legal
requirements policies and procedures in
taking the actions we reviewed or
alternatively whether the circumstances
surrounding the decision indicated it
was based on inaccurate or incomplete
information or considerations other than
the merits of the investigation if the
explanations we were given for a
particular decision were consistent with
legal requirements policies procedures
and not unreasonable we didn't conclude
that the decision was based on improper
considerations so in other words if you
could give any excuse at all that
avoided violating the law they would buy
it that's what that that Stan
is and here is what they found they
found that the investigation was not
initiated in bad faith by the way I tend
to agree with that now what you're
seeing is that their statements put out
by Bill Barr and also John Durham both
of other members of the DOJ right
they'll bars the Attorney General Don
John Durham his a US Attorney who's
doing his own investigation into the
origins of Trump Russia collusion
investigation both of them came out they
said well we disagree with this
assessment by the IG now remember the IG
was only examining the FBI was not
examining the CIA was not examining the
other members of the intelligence
community not foreign countries just the
FBI so according to this IG report
crossfire hurricane was opened as a full
investigation all of the senior FBI
officials who participated in
discussions about whether to open a case
told us the information warranted
opening it says we concluded that under
the AG guidelines and the domestic
investigations operation guide the FBI
had an authorized purpose when it opened
crossfire hurricane to obtain
information about or protect against a
national security threat or federal
crime even though the investigation also
had the potential to impact
constitutionally protected activity
additionally given the low threshold for
predication in the AG guidelines and the
di oggi we concluded that the friendly
foreign government information provided
by a government the US intelligence
community deems trustworthy and
describing a first-hand account from a
foreign government of a conversation
with George papadopolis low-level Trump
staffer was sufficient to predicating
the investigation in other words it's a
very low standard for opening an
investigation there's a conversation
that happened between George papadopolis
low-level from foreign policy aide who
had a conversation with a member of the
Australian government in which she
bragged about having had a conversation
with a guy named Joseph Mifsud who was
seen by the intelligence community as a
Russian cutout who had said that he had
information that the Russians had access
to Hillary Clinton's emails and would
give them to the Trump campaign and that
was the predication for the opening of
this investigation now you combine that
with Paul manna for joining the campaign
and with the intelligence community
being suspicious of Carter page Donald
Trump's more more de Tourvel a mere
Putin and this was apparently enough to
open the investigation now John Durham
says no right John Durham put out a
statement saying our investigation has
included developing information from
other persons and entities both in the
US and
side the US based on the evidence
collected to date and while our
investigation is ongoing
last month we advise the Inspector
General we do not agree with some of the
reports conclusions asked to predication
and how the FBI case was open so that
sounds like there might be some
different grounds for opening it
Attorney General William Barr said the
same thing he says the inspector
general's report now makes clear that
the FBI launched an intrusive
investigation of the u.s. presidential
campaign on the thinnest of suspicions
that in my view were insufficient to
justify the steps take him it is also
clear that from its inception the
evidence produced by the investigation
was consistently exculpatory
nevertheless the investigation and
surveillance was pushed forward for the
duration of the campaign and deep into
president Trump's administration some
people on left look why are you ripping
the IG stop ripping it well maybe
they're more information than the IG
we're gonna have to wait to see what bar
has and people are saying bars and
political hack terms now political hack
okay why don't we wait for the
information they will present and then
we will determine where the political
hackery occurred was it inside the IGS
report or was it here or is it possible
that it's not political hackery
on any side then maybe the IG is just
looking at the stuff inside the FBI and
making the conclusion based on the bare
legal requirement and bar and Durham
have other information maybe that's the
case maybe they disagree and all of
these could be possible there is one
thing that is certain and one thing is
certain here the FBI
blew it with regard to for example the
Carter page FISA warrant the FBI was
acting right at the margins of its
authority in using confidential human
sources to ferret out information from
the Trump campaign the report says we
found it concerning the Department and
FBI policy did not require the FBI to
consult with any Department official in
advance of conducting confidential human
source operations involving advisors to
a major parties presidential campaign we
found no evidence the FBI consulted with
any DOJ officials before conducting
these operations as we described
consultation at a minimum is required by
Department and FBI policies we include a
recommendation to address the issue so
even this report says you guys were
operating right at the boundaries of
your authority and in some cases beyond
there were 717 inaccuracies and
emissions in the Carter page FISA
warrants according to the report FBI
personnel quote fell far short of the
requirements regarding the FISA warrant
the FBI one member
lawyer altered evidence that falsely
cast Carter Paige as a Russian spy NBC's
Pete Williams gets it right he says
listen they're basically screw-ups at
every single level here so while the
media are proclaiming that the FBI is
exonerated everybody's good no evidence
of bias there are scripts at every level
and all of the scrubs cut in one
direction here is NBC's Pete Williams
acknowledging as much nonetheless it
says it found no political bias in
seeking the FISA warrant on Paige what
it says is the FBI basically repeatedly
screwed up at every level failing to pay
enough attention to potential problems
with steel failing to tell the Justice
Department and it says at one point that
the FBI decided to seek this FISA
warrant even at the risk of being
criticized for doing it later because
the report says FBI officials they had
said they had to get to the bottom of a
potentially serious threat to national
security okay so yeah again this report
it ain't good for the FBI and anybody in
the media telling you that it is that's
just because Trump may of you know over
pitched what he thought would happen
here but we selves away from bar and
Durham there may be more information
forthcoming okay time for a quick thing
I like and a quick thing that I hate so
things that I like there is this bizarre
notion in in anti religious communities
that religious people never think about
their religion at all and that religious
people spend all day walking around in
sort of a blind stupor thinking oh well
everything that happens is is good
because God did it and I don't suffer
and there is no suffering and one of the
examples they use is oh look at all
those those athletes who every time they
score a touchdown they point to the sky
or they thank God after game so they
really think that God is making them win
the game that's so stupid okay that no
what's stupid is that you actually think
that a lot of people believe that what
most people who are religious believe is
that yes God's hand is providential God
does have a will we don't always
understand what exactly God is doing but
we don't actually believe that if you
are good and nice and good Christian
that you're gonna score a touchdown on
every pass Nick Foles is having a rough
season for the Jacksonville Jaguars he's
a religious Christian he was asked about
a bad game and he preaches a basic
religious message with regard to the
impact of God in everyday events I've
been able still to get to know people
get to know these guys through an injury
though I might not be playing
that is difficult from a fleshly
perspective but from the spiritual
perspective for my heart I've been able
to grow as a human being to where I feel
like I'm at a better situation here as a
person that I was before because of the
trial I just went under and I know
that's a sermon in itself but that's how
I go through life and the good Lords
been there too you know it's not always
about prosperity I don't believe in the
prosperity gospel I believe if you read
the Word of God and you understand it
there's trials along the way but they
equip your heart to be who you are okay
that okay that is religion right the
religious perspective is that not that
everything you do is going to earn you
wealth and happiness and that if you're
religious that all good things come to
you religious people suffer I mean in
Christianity the founder of the religion
suffers a great deal right I mean that
in Judaism Moses doesn't go into the
promised land suffering is not is not
avoided simply by believing in God or
doing the right thing
nobody who's religious truly religious
believes this but we do believe that if
you overcome those trials if you engage
in those trials if you engage in that
struggle with justice in the universe
and God then it makes you stronger equip
better equipped to handle those trials
good for Nick Foles good for Nick Foles
being a good messenger for a godly
message okay time for a quick thing that
I hate okay so a marriage story it's
getting all sorts of plaudits there are
two movies that have gotten all sorts of
plot it's already ripped one of them
last week the irishman martin scorsese
film which is interminable and listen
I've been a longtime critic of Scorsese
I think Scorsese is overrated as a
director I find all of his films to
Center in on people who are just
disgusting and I don't find any of his
characters particularly interesting I
will acknowledge his style but in in the
Irishman he basically just is just three
and a half hours of vomit I mean it's
never-ending okay so I ripped down
Scorsese he got all sorts of Golden
Globes nominations last night now I'm
gonna rip on a marriage story so a
marriage story is a Noah Baumbach
production
he basically focuses in on obnoxious
people on the Upper East Side it's
basically a bunch of Upper East Side
artists who have no moral compass or a
moral code and we're supposed to care
deeply about them because they write
literature which is like
so tired and so boring in any case he
makes this movie a marriage story Adam
driver is terrific in it Scarlett
Johansson is terrific in it all the
acting is great Laura Dern who I love is
is terrific in it all the acting is
great it is a movie about obnoxious
people being obnoxious not giving a crap
about their child being obnoxious to the
to each other without caring about the
kid and predicating a divorce on
essentially the basis that they want to
have different career paths I mean you
want to know why I found like the fact
people are finding it's emotionally
affecting I think is is quite a problem
for people's perception of morality
here's a little bit of the preview you
know most people in my business features
transactions to them I don't like to
think of it was people oh okay good you
remind me of myself on my second
marriage
[Music]
what we're gonna do together is tell me
your story you dye your hair again well
this is me
you don't like it is it shortened I
prefer a longer but how are you doing
and tell about how they negotiate the
divorce and all the problems that
they're having with each other and it's
so emotional and so if I can accept both
these people are garbage
they're both garbage you know he's
cheating on her because he's a bad
person and she basically says that she
is divorcing him because she never felt
fulfilled
so it's like both characters are Meryl
Streep in Kramer vs Kramer I've seen
this compared to Kramer vs Kramer yeah
the only difference is that in Kramer vs
Kramer Dustin Hoffman is the good guy
there's no good guy here everybody sucks
everybody's terrible if either of them
took 15 seconds to consider the fact
that they have a child whose life will
be devastated by the fact that they are
getting divorced and maybe they might
think about the fact that actually they
share a lot in common and if they could
make themselves better then they'd stay
together for the kids it's very angry
Indies I think that it is a generalized
perception on marriage the marriage is
just there for the good of the two
people as opposed to being about the
creation and raising of the child and it
does demonstrate the stupidity of our
divorce system which is really quite
garbage Rhee
but aside from that I the people in this
movie are so obnoxious that I
legitimately could not tell whether the
director is attempting to mock them when
you watch the trailer it's pretty
obvious that it's meant to be sincere
but I I watched the movie and I kept
thinking to myself is he making fun of
the shallowness of these people because
if he's not and he's being sincere about
why we're supposed to care about these
people that doesn't say a lot of great
things about the writer and director and
doesn't say a lot of great things about
the people who find this movie supremely
emotionally affecting my goodness like
why don't any of these people ever like
sit and have a think about the kind of
life they want to create for their child
as opposed to themselves the entire
movies about themselves yeah
as a parent I spend very little of my
day thinking about the life I want to
create for me and I think a lot about
the life I want to create for my
children
so does my wife it's one of the reasons
we have a good marriage and one of the
reasons I think that we hope we're good
parents already we'll be back here a
little bit later today with two
additional hours of content we have some
great guests we're going to be analyzing
everything impeachment related and all
the rest i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Rebecca Dodd poets directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling technical producer Austin
Stephens associate producer Colton Haas
assistant director pavel white house key
edited by adam sai events audio is mixed
by micro Mina hair and makeup is by Jess
WA alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host
of the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clifford
[Music]